it has everything Hollywood movies wish
they had today
we have another quote here we've done
this with you in the past and uh we're
wondering if you can read this quote
here
and uh not sure if you know who it is
but
uh let's see if I can figure it out okay
I feel like I'm on a game show now
um I am a filmmaker my job is to make
films when something excites you a story
or characterization you immediately
forget about everything else you only
think how to make a movie out of it the
economics come only later you shouldn't
let money dictate the kind of films you
should make
well I I really love that statement I'm
not exactly sure who wrote it but
I love that I think well there's a
couple of things it's it's an it's
unfortunate that
um filmmaking is the most expensive art
form
even if you make a film on your iPhone
at some point you're gonna have to do a
professional sound mix you're gonna have
to use color correction you're gonna
have to spend some money to market the
film
right so even movies at a low budget
level money is sort of the unspoken
producer of every movie
that's why when you see the movies with
the highest budgets you know many times
they appeal to everyone and no one
and don't exactly leave leave you with
any sort of lasting impression
but I think money is always the unspoken
producer and in addition money is for
many beginning filmmakers an excuse to
not make a movie
so
I feel like you need to kind of set all
those excuses aside find out what your
Baseline level budget is to tell a story
and if there's a way to do it leap right
in but now you have to tell me who said
this I I don't know speaking of leap
thinking of the dancing scene that would
be SS Raj muli
wow wow yeah Essence Raja muli said that
wow that's fantastic he um
I'm become a quick fan of ss rajamouli
he directed a film called RR which is a
tollywood film
it's it's really interesting in India
they really have competing film
Industries they have Bollywood which
many people are familiar with Bollywood
and Associate most of Indian Cinema with
Bollywood but there's also tollywood
uh and and there I think that the
rivalry between the two industries is
actually made for better films
uh and I will say
I discovered RR when it was number three
at the box office the weekend that the
Batman opened
and I found that really strange how is
it that the weekend that this biggest
superhero movie you know Robert
Pattinson is the Batman that this movie
rrr
suddenly is Unleashed in the United
States
and
I went to see it on a whim based on a
recommendation from a friend and
noticing like how did this film and the
film just blew my mind three hour epic
very Loosely based on two historical
figures
and it has everything Hollywood movies
wish they had today
just compelling instantly likable
characters it very much felt like an old
style Hollywood movie a mix of you know
yes there are dance numbers there's also
romance and humor action there's heroism
acts of self-sacrifice I don't know that
Hollywood can make a film like RR and
it's it's really disappointing to me
oddly enough
um RR is the I believe the highest
budget movie
ever to come from India at 75 million
dollars
and it's it's really quite an
achievement when you see the film I
would have thought it would be it would
have been in the hundreds of millions of
dollars to make this movie
but the fact that it's 75 million
dollars and so epic in scale
there's a scene in at the near the
beginning of the film in the First Act
character named ROM who is an officer at
an outpost it's being protested
and it's an action sequence where ROM is
sort of set on a mission to to grab a
perpetrator who threw a rock
he goes to try to track down this
perpetrator it's an epic action scene
you can't believe I mean it's just
something on a scale we've never seen I
was shocked to learn that they took
almost 30 days to shoot that scene with
20 000 extras not digital effects
twenty thousand extras
so
the achievement of this film is so
remarkable
and
it makes me sad that like hey you know
Hollywood can't compete with this
and I I do see when you go to your local
Cinema
wherever your local movie theater is
you're seeing more and more you know not
necessarily your Hollywood movie but
anime
you're seeing Spanish language films
Indian films I mean
um at the AMC theaters that I go to in
Southern California there is at least a
new Indian movie every month sometimes
two a month
I personally love that because I've
always enjoyed you know uh World Cinema
has I I've always enjoyed it but this
film is something special
one interesting thing that I would point
out about RR
is
Americans reaction to this movie
everyone I know that has seen it has
really loved it but what I find
interesting is we live at a time where
politics is infused into nearly every
art form comic books writing movies
television
it's uh I I could use a break frankly
from being lectured to no one likes to
be lectured to and this film does not do
that but there are thematically some
interesting things that are opposing in
it and I'm really surprised that that
I've never seen anyone point this out
about rrr on the one hand
the villains of the film are the
colonizers you know the British
the Sun never sets on the British
Empires what they say and there's a
character governor Scott in in rrr that
is I mean he is a villain right out of a
Star Wars movie with the British accent
and whatnot so the white Colonial
Invaders of India are the bad people
now that is a political messaging
it's also a real historical thing that
happened okay so it's not like it's a
message but
that's something that would appeal to
one side of the political aisle would be
hey the colonizers are the baddies in
this movie
in addition in the same movie
there is also a thread about guns
and
owning a gun and the correct use of a
gun responsible use of a weapon
will lead to Freedom
the character ROM who I mentioned
earlier you get a flashback in the
second half of the film with young RAM
and his father
and he's teaching him about the value of
a bullet the value of a bullet being you
know worth more than the life of an
Indian
uh and and and how that kind of plays
through he tells them the value of
bullet what it can do responsible gun
use you see sort of training an army to
to basically you know
fight their way to freedom from the
British colonizers
so on the one hand you have a movie
that's very
anti-colonizer that is also very
pro-second Amendment you could look at
it that way I don't think I've seen a
movie
I can't even think of a film that
contains
if you've seen the movie RR as many
times as I have you'll notice it
two opposing
sides of the political aisle in terms of
messaging one being anti-colonizer
another one being pro-gun
um I don't know that SS Roger Mali
intended it to be that way I don't
believe he's lecturing in any portion of
the film at all I think it's all organic
to the story I just find it fascinating
that not one person has pointed this out
that's interesting I hadn't even thought
of it I'm referring back to the scene
that you're talking about and there's
also just to keep it lighter there's
friendship there's romance there's
amazing dance sequences and then there's
these animals right animals all
digitally the animals are all digitally
created right but also rahm's Mission
which his sort of his his family is
decimated and murdered by the the
colonizers right by the British
um the British soldiers wipe out his
family and his tribe nearly everyone in
his tribe and then he grows up and he's
on a mission to get the guns because
guns will lead to freedom and if I mean
India was not United as a country at the
time this
for a historical frame of reference the
story the story of our art takes place
in the 1920s
uh it's also based on two real
historical figures and imagines if they
had met right
um they never actually didn't meet but
but the film kind of is is definitely I
would call it historical fantasy
but you the you know India was not
United as a country it was
um groups of tribes
and and the British colonizers coming in
kind of helped unite the people
and and the the Ram's mission is his
whole mission is to get weapons and then
deliver them to his tribes so they can
fight for their freedom and at least
fight on an even playing field with the
British having guns and them having guns
so
um you know these are sensitive things
to think about and talk about because
we live at a time where you know even if
you reveal even a hint at what your
politics might be it could be a death
sentence for a career which is sad to me
it's sad that we can't have open and
honest conversations about
a whole number of issues I would love to
be able to do that
but it's funny that this wildly
successful
um very mainstream and entertaining
almost a tip of the hat to old Hollywood
film RR has woven into it
some messages you could read read in
that are that are uh that are right in
the middle of the Divide of where people
are right now in the United States and
are they on two different religious
spectrums as well in the film no they
don't not so much
I mean the film does deal with that but
what I love about SS rajamouli as a
filmmaker he was asked in an interview
or the interviewer asked him said hey
have you thought about doing a Marvel
movie you should
you know based on the action in rrr you
should be making a Marvel movie
and SS Raja Mali said I have no interest
in doing a Marvel movie I don't want to
do that and he wants to keep his focus
on telling stories from Indian history
and Indian mysticism and and fables and
I think that that is why I so admire uh
Raja Mali is a filmmaker because he
wants to stick to his roots
you know and I I think that that's
incredibly admirable
did you expect to love the movie going
in
I didn't know I didn't know what to
expect about RR when I went in to see it
I I just thought well okay it's three
hours I I know I'm gonna have to take a
break
at some point there's going to be an
intermission whether there is one or not
but I just fell in love with it because
because it reminded me of a type of
movie that Hollywood used to make which
wasn't any genre you could easily just
say well RR is an action movie it's not
just that it's also a historical fantasy
it's also a love story in fact there are
two love stories
maybe three if you encount if you count
the friendship between beam and ROM
so
it really is you know in my top
probably top five if not top three
movies of the year
and it should give Hollywood pause
to see how successful this film is
internationally how it's beloved by
anyone that sees it if there's a way to
see rrr in a movie theater I strongly
recommend it
um
I you know I've seen it in the theater
four times I'm actually going to see it
for a fifth time in the theater and when
you see this movie it's like a
celebration I haven't seen an audience
react this way to a film in a theater
since the very end of you know uh
Avengers end game that sort of swell of
you don't want to just clap you want to
stand up and applaud you want to scream
for joy
I mean I can think of times in the past
where I've you know screamed at a movie
theater and and applauded uh for Joy but
I haven't done that
I haven't done that with a Hollywood
film probably since that scene and end
game the portals scene which is the the
very end of the film I thought that was
like that was the combination of 10
years of Marvel movies and and telling
effectively what turned out to be one
story leading to that epic battle
Nothing Compares except for the film RR
and and seeing it in the theater is for
me um if it's playing I'm gonna go uh
I'm just so taken with this film and I
think there's so much there's so much to
learn from it and I really hope that
Hollywood learns the lesson of you know
please stop the lecturing
tell audiences a story that they can be
engaged with
with characters that you fall in love
with
and I think I think really that formula
is fairly simple I don't I don't know
where we got to this place where we felt
it necessary to infuse all of our
entertainment with
uh
with with some sort of lecturing it's
just you just don't need it
and it's tollywood you said tollywood
yes
um there yeah you know I am still
learning about all this my understanding
is they're two dominant languages in
India there's Telugu and Hindi and
sometimes you will see
um you know they'll come out in
different languages I'm obviously I'm
seeing it with the subtitles I can't
speak either language
um the only words I know are not to natu
which is the dance number the dance
number in in the middle of our RR
were ROM and beam do the not to not to
dance right then it turns into a
dance-off
some people some friends of mine have
recommended rr2 they they kind of cringe
for a minute like oh is it's one of
those Bollywood movies with dance
numbers and I correct them because I was
corrected it's Hollywood and and the
dance number is a big part of the story
it's a huge part of the story so it's
not just put in there just to be in
there right there's a purpose there's a
purpose for not to not to to be in the
middle of that and God I wish I had the
skills that those actors did in that
scene it's it's it's really really
remarkable
so
God just
if I could say one thing just go see RR
in the theater if you have the
opportunity
you can thank me later